gut dann können wir beginn der letzten
sitzung hatten wir leider nicht mehr
ganz diesen text auf normen mal kommen
lesen können
zum thema gedankenlose tieren das werden
wir heute das ende lesen und dann werden
wir in der zweiten hälfte auf ein text
von donnell davidson zu sprechen kommt
also wir haben jetzt wie der heutigen
sitzung definitiv die historischen
debatten abgehakt noch nicht ganz bei
diesem text hier kommt der cartes noch
mal vor
aber jetzt geht es ganz klar die
gegenwart in die moderne technologie
das haben wir bereits daran gesehen dass
hier ganz häufig von begriffen wie pro
positionen die rede ist also von termini
die aus dem modernen philosophie des
geistes stammen und mit diesen
kategorien wollen wir jetzt diese
historischen texte versuchen zu
begreifen
die karte selbst spricht ja nicht von
positionen
er spricht nicht von intentional i tät
und so weiter und so fort
aber wir wollen jetzt einfach mal
schauen ob diese ganzen akte des geistes
wie wir ihn hier im seminar zu beginn ja
versucht haben mehr zum reisen also
bewusst sein schreibt noch mal hin
bewusst sein selbstbewusstsein war die
zustände
die natürlich auch irgendwas mit
bewusstsein zu tun haben
gedanken proposition
ich habe immer den gedanken dass der
gedanke dass also auch gedanken kann man
hier in die form von proposition
umbringen
ich denke dass und ganz wichtig auch
noch vielleicht mit einem wichtigsten
die sprache hallo sprache sprache das
sind so die ganzen punkte die den geist
aus machen natürlich ein sehr engen
begriff von geist ich habe im besetzen
sind im letzten jahr eine tagung
organisiert mit dem titel die aktualität
des geistes da kommt jetzt auch ein
sammelband raus und in auf dieser tagung
stand ein ganz anderer begriff des
geistes im zentrum dass ich will es
einfach noch mal betont das ist das ist
das mentale hier an dem wir sprechen
mentales wäre es im sinne von
dieser tradition dass man sagt
geschichte die geschichtliche phänomene
dass man sagt
theologie und sagt wie hegel der geist
und dass das das ende einer entwicklung
der endpunkt auf den alles hin läuft
dass man sagt ich und welt
das ist das verhältnis zwischen ich und
welt irgendwas mit dem geist zu tun hat
davon ist hier nicht die rede
es gibt aber noch einen anderen prägung
von geist wie es der deutsche begriff
und geist ein bisschen eilig ich habe
schon mal gesagt der geist des 19
jahrhunderts
der geist der stadt münchen der geist
dieser religion dieser religion
das ist eine verbindung von geist die
hier nicht recht am platze ist
dennoch kann man so von guise treten
auch sinnvoller egal ist einer sprache
natürlich das ist dann natürlich
wiederum was anderes im sinn von der
sprache im sinne des mentalen hier kommt
dann so was wie semantik
semantik syntax während hiergeist im
geist des italienischen italienischen
sprache dass sie sehen das ist eine
völlig andere verwendungsfähig möchte
aber ich möchte ja nicht partei
ergreifen für die ein oder andere
verbindungspreise ich glaube dass beide
ihre berechtigung haben so eine
verwendung zweier sind sagt der geist
kommt eine geschichte vor
die ist natürlich viel voraussetzung
voller die ist durchaus begründung
bedürftiger als eine sehr enge
verbindung von geist aber ich möchte das
nicht von vornherein ausschließen nur um
es uns hier geht das ist einfach nur
diese linke seite das sind unsere bezüge
genau jetzt können wir hier wieder mit
dem text reingehen wir haben ich leider
nicht ganz zu ende gelesen er sagt jetzt
hier folgendes also die card ist in
diesem text der bezugspunkt wir gehen
einfach flott durch und schauen ob wir
dem zustimmen können oder nicht er sagt
so wie ich die karte verstehe stellt er
sich explizit und bewusst auf den
standpunkt dass jedes fühlen jeder
wunsch wieder wesentlich ab wie das
gefühl und jede empfindung einen
proportionalen kern hat deswegen kann er
behaupten dass seine wesentliche natur
nur darin bestehe einzig und allein
denken des dienstes seien nicht von der
coop italia und pussy außerordentlich
großzügig verwendet zählt der einbildung
empfindungen gefühl zum denken sind weil
er überzeugt ist dass jede mentale
tätigkeit im einnehmen einer einstellung
gegenüber einer proposition besteht
also man kann sich ja fragen bei
descartes wie kommt es dass so
verschiedene dinge wie wir wollen nicht
wollen empfinden schreibt es mal groß
verneinen
wie kommt es dass diese ganzen phänomene
hier auch ein finden sind tiere hat eine
wie kommt es dass die karte die alle als
geistige akte bezeichnet man könnte auch
sagen der tiere empfinden doch auch aber
nach descartes sind sie eben keine
seelischen wesen die irgendwie mit rees
mit einer rees kogge tanz in verbindung
stehen und der grund sagt jetzt unser
auto hier ist der dass die karts wohl
meint dass jeder diese akte hier wollen
nicht wollen empfinden bejahen verneinen
und so weiter und so fort dass der das
einnehmen einer einstellung gegenüber
einer proposition bedeutet also ich will
das und dass das ist die proposition ich
will dass dix oder ich empfinde hicks
findungs zustand das xperia x10 ja die
proposition und da kann man natürlich
dann durchaus zu diskutieren sagen haben
tiere verfügen tiere überproportionale
einstellung im empfinden haben ihre
positionen vor augen
sechs fenster hier darauf machen ja
das kann man sich wirklich fragen jetzt
will ich jetzt gern immer zur debatte
stellen haben da hinten kann man gerne
auch noch aufmachen wenn es gewünscht
ist aber sie sagen sie melden sich
einfach mal sind ja zwei fenster immer
machen muss wir haben tiere ist
funktioniert das jetzt so mit tieren
also oder auch bei uns ja proposition
proposition euro pro position
ganz klar zu verstehen
[Musik]
proposition bedeutet nicht vorstellungen
pro position bedeutet einfach nur ein
sachverhalt in die form eines das satzes
bringen
alles was hier eingefüllt werden kann
dieses lehrfilm die sonne heute ist ein
schöner tag also eine eine eine
wahrheits fähige aussage eine aussage
die wahrheit' wert fähig ist die falsche
oder oder oder oder richtig sein kann zb
die die aussage also positionen sind in
der regel aussage oder vorschläge in der
position ist eine vorschlag pro pro
probe heißt vorschlagen vorlegen
als eine these könnte man auch die these
dass ich behaupte dass ich behaupte dass
heute 50 leute in diesem raum sitzen ist
dass das heute 50 leuten diesem haben
sitzt eine position und diese position
kann wahr oder falsch seien sie ist
falsch weil 50 sitzen ja nicht drin
vielleicht 30 oder 20
und alles was sind diese form gebracht
werden kann
also was auch letztlich war heizwert
fähig ist
ja und jetzt kann natürlich sagen gut
muss jetzt im zehnten wirklich etwas mit
einer proposition zu tun haben als ich
empfinde jetzt dringend etwas wurde ich
will
das oder kann ich wollen irgendwie schon
so ein bisschen vor proportionalen
strukturiert seien es zieht mich einfach
hin zu etwas muss das schon aufs in form
einer eine position angegeben werden
könnte card scheint das zumindest nach
diesem text hier und ich glaube dass da
was dran ist zum einen dass das die
ganze nacht die für ihn für die karts
sind das alles akte der rest geht an die
denken die substanz die ist durch solche
akte kennzeichnet das problem ist
folgendes man kann doch sagen diese
ganzen akte hier empfinden sind tiere
nicht wollen wollen die finden wir auch
bei tieren und wenn wir die bei tieren
empfinden dann heißt das dass sie auch
mehrere kitas haben aber die charaktere
sind keine haben keine disco getanzt
tiere müssen wir so ansehen als ob sie
kein geld hätten
also haben wir hier probleme und der
grund warum die karte jetzt das nur den
menschlichen geist zu sprechen könnte
die mure riss kompetenz zu sprechen
könnte könnte eben der sein der sagt
wollen ist immer wollen das wollen von
etwas bestimmten was ich auf eine
professionelle struktur hier bringen
lässt und das haben wir bei tieren nicht
das ist so wohl dass das problem her
ich empfinde das ich empfinde das genau
das ist das ist das argument gegen die
karte
franken
die möglichkeit sich als in
genau es gibt zwei möglichkeiten der
autor den wir hier lesen der vertritt
wollen was die these die hier verhandelt
wird in diesem text ist die dass die
auszeichnung als rees koki tanz darin
besteht dass das mit proposition zu tun
hat es gibt noch eine andere lesart was
man sagt diese ganzen akte hier sind
deswegen ausgezeichnet weil sie immer
einig als eine art transzendenten grund
transzendentalen grund vor sich liegen
haben also wollen es immer ich wollen
als ich will ich bin derjenige dass wir
als alle diese akte sind gezogen auf
einig könnte man sagen
auf den letzten grund unsere
transzendentalen ich was das ganze die
ganzen dinge hier vereint die diesen
akten der einheit verleiht dieses dich
und das könnte man auch sagen ist bei
tieren nicht so passieren ist nicht
einig bewusstsein fanden was diese
ganzen akte vereint das wäre eine andere
möglichkeit die jetzt hier nicht
thematisiert
vielleicht steckt das
wenn stellen
das muss ich mich ja auch schon wieder
kann man kann man weiter diskutieren
kann jetzt fragen ob eine position aale
einstellung dem so ein starkes ich
voraussetzt
ich denke ich empfinde das konnte schon
gut sein weil schauen sie mal dazu dass
sie in der lage sind eine empfindung auf
so eine form zu bringen müssen sie sich
ja von ihrer empfindung auch
distanzieren können
sie müssen sich unterscheiden oder sich
als jemanden sehen der diese empfindung
hat sie müssen ihre empfindung
objektivieren das ist eine
objektivierung das also wenn sie das auf
eine position bringen haben sie
objektiviert und das scheint
vorauszusetzen dass ich mich
unterscheiden kann von meinen oder dass
ich mich in meiner ganzen akte bewusst
werden kann um sie auf diese das form zu
bringen
das richtig also man kann durchaus sagen
dieses diese position eine struktur
bekommen wir nur dann wenn wir ein
starkes ich ein starkes nicht bewusst
seien voraussetzen
okay das ist jetzt interpretation von
der karte zeigt er war der auto verhält
sich jetzt kritisch zu dieser lesart
meiner meinung nach ist dies eine
absurde über intellektualisierung sicht
auf das menschliche leben allerdings ist
sie hilfreich wenn wir verstehen wollen
warum die karte dachte tiere seien
automaten sie besitzen kein geist
keinerlei bewusstsein oder gewahr sein
und kein wirkliches fühlen oder keine
wirkliche empfindung weil sie keine
position erfassen erwägen betrachten
oder im klartext weil sie nie an
positionen denken also der auto verhält
sich kritisch zu dieser auffassung
wie stehen sie dazu ist es eine über
intellektualisierung sich selbst des
menschlichen lebens
da hatten sie ja schon bei spiel
gebracht das sei nicht immer eine
proportionale struktur zugrunde liegen
muss man könnte es aber sagen gut panik
dass es dann wieder so eine
kurzschlussreaktion da geht irgendwie so
eine nervenverbindung an unserem
kontrollzentrum vorbei im gehirn einfach
dass es so ein schneller schaltkreis
weil die evolution und so eingerichtet
hat dass wir in solchen film einfach gar
nicht denken weil sonst wenn wir denken
würden würden wir nicht überleben
richtig könnte man sagen genommen
genau
keine wirklichen sagt aber keine
richtigen emotionen sind es ja also ja
es ist der autor hier sagt also die
karts scheint einzubringen zu
intellektuell ist ischen begriff zu
haben gelesen weiter im wirklichen leben
leben verwenden wir das verb denken oft
in bezug auf tiere
wir sagen pause denkt er werde gleich
gefüttert genauso selbstverständlich wie
edward hauser will gefüttert werden
nehmen wir eine an unser hund jage die
nachbarskatze diese rast mit volldampf
auf eine eiche zu schwenkt aber im
letzten moment plötzlich ab und
verschwindet auf einem nahen ahorn der
hund sieht dieses manöver und stellt
sich nicht und stellt sich bei derartig
angekommen auf die hinterbeine kratz mit
den pfoten am stammen als vorher
hochklettern und welt aufgelegt den
ersten hoch wir die wir die episode vom
fenster aus beobachten sagen er denkt
die katze sei diese arche hochgeklettert
wir sagen denkt weil er einen falschen
baum hinauf bild wenn die katze
tatsächlich die eiche hinaufgeklettert
wäre und er holt sich genauso aufgeführt
hätte hätten wir sagen können er weiß
dass die katze diese eiche
hinaufgeklettert ist aber bleiben wir
bei denkt man könnte tausende von
beispielen anführen
in denen man von einem tier korrekter
weise so etwas sagen würde wie es denkt
dass die karts behauptung dass tiere
nicht denken steckt ganz klar ein fehler
wir können gerne noch dieses fenster
hinten aufnahmen sie wollen
es sind immer zwei scheiben muss also
noch das zweite auch noch auf machen das
dahinterliegende
ist doch der der den anwesenden hier
angenehme oder schließe jetzt einfach
mal so ja aber sie müssen einfach
reagieren also wenn es ihnen jetzt am
fenster zu kalt ist natürlich
ist es ihnen zu kalt am fenster als sie
müssen jetzt einfach irgendwie
kommunizieren und interagieren
ja ich möchte nur dass es eben hier gut
geht weil der auch die klimatische
atmosphäre des denkens wesentlich
beeinflusst
ja wie sieht es jetzt hier aus mit
diesem text
ich bin ich sagen also weil mir der ist
einer der
hier
das muss das ist hier ist 90
nicht nach
ja aber richtig also die frage ist
natürlich immer wir müssen einen schluss
ziehen wir ziehen ein schluss wie
interpretieren die ganze sache handelt
es sich jetzt dabei um eine
interpretation
sicherlich noch aber gibt es gute gründe
diese diese annahme zu treffen dass der
hund denkt und dass er davon ausgeht
oder so
das anderen leistungen vom 5
ja aber hier war noch eine minute
diese dokumente werden so zu sein dass
die tatsache dass wir der persönliche
begriffe unter anderen die denken
schreiben stand d20 zu erleben
die katze zwischen görg sagte diese
angst oder die spd des dicken scheck
deswegen einmal sehen dass in den
kanzler stellen aber die verwendung von
sprache also von alltag sportlichem
schwarz heute nennen gehen
dadurch dass der offensichtlich an der
eigentlich hab ich drauf ist und kanada
sind nicht mehr gehabt dass die kapsel
ein wenig sieht dass das deshalb nicht
ob denn da kann immer was besser das
gewinde zugeschrieben werden
sie haben alle ich denke sie haben recht
es ist ein induktions also bestimmt
einen schluss ist eine interpretation
aber man hat natürlich auch gute gründe
dafür gute anhaltspunkte davon
auszugehen weil da eine intention ali t
enthalten ist das muss ich auch noch ein
schreib internationalität
internationalität seine richtung der
hund der ist ganz klar gerichtet auf
etwas
ich glaube dass natürlich auch dieses
gerichtet seine interpretation ist aber
der hund gibt auch sehr stark
einrichtung vor
also dass er dass sie sich zu etwas hin
orientiert das auf etwas hin strebt das
ist nicht nur jetzt glaube ich
interpretation von uns sind dann hat man
also schon sehr gute gründe sondern
streben oder in ordnung anzunehmen
scheint mir schon die frage ist nur dann
ob davon eben ausgehend ein gedanke auch
abgeleitet werden kann
die frage ist wird intensität zu
gedanken verhelfen ja
entsprechend lang ist
jede werden man könnte sie auch
bescheinigt eine reaktionskette wieandt
auf die katze
so empfiehlt ihnen bereits den darüber
fast verständlich und dann bleibt er auf
den letzten rängen
gut also dass da jetzt einfach so konnte
nicht konditioniert ist es nicht der
richtige ausdruck oder so fehlgeleitet
ist nur dass fehler orientiert und diese
orientierung würden sie jetzt nicht als
einen gedanken interpretieren ja ok
leuchtet mir ein also natürlich liegt es
auf der hand zu haben er hat den
gedanken sei er wurde jetzt dorthin
gelockt wurde dorthin gelotst und
gespurt sein programm ab
die platte
das haben sie schön gesagt mit der
platte wald das jetzt natürlich ganz auf
der karte sischen linie liegt die platte
das ist natürlich dieser mechanismus
also in dieser metaphorik jedenfalls
eine karte card könnte jetzt so wie sie
es tun argumentieren ja da war noch mehr
doch das
jetzt wollen wir das
klasse
es liegt da ein schluss liegt er beim
hund eine eine noch so rudimentäre
kalkulation ein gedankengang diesmal zu
grunde haben wir anhaltspunkte davon
einer schlussfolgerung auszugehen
wir haben jetzt zwei mögliche
argumentationsweise kommilitonen sagte
es ist einfach der folgt diesem in steht
die sind im jagdinstinkt gibt dem
instinkt nach erfolgt soweit wieder
instinkt greift und information bietet
an dieser stelle setzt das ganze aus da
kommt der instinkt nicht mehr zum zug
weil einfach kein objekt mehr da ist
nicht nur den hut ziehen
er wird wahrscheinlich der spur ach so
ja es gibt natürlich die möglichkeit auf
eine falsche spur dann gefolgt ist also
das irgendwie eine spur gewittert hat an
diesem baum
man muss jetzt wirklich vorstellen als
er rennt jetzt hier
es ist praktisch so von oben jetzt
betrachtet hier brennt hier lang und und
die katze geht aber hier hin und erfolgt
aber dieser
diese sozial sowie er sich wirklich gibt
und der unseren sich einfach mal anders
oder
entschuldigt
ja
er könnte ja auch einer sinnestäuschung
erlebnis sein dass er eben diesen moment
hier verpasst wo die katze abbiegt zumal
der rothenbaum liegt ein bisschen näher
hier der blick mehr auf dieser achse
also dieser hier wo sie nicht drauf ist
der hier ja richtig also es ist dann
praktisch eine sinnestäuschung eine
sinnestäuschung
zukünftig kann das machen wir suchen und
anzunehmen
liegen so tun als ob er den deckel
finden
ist das jetzt aber ist das jetzt ein
falscher gedanke des hundes das ist
gutes beispiel ist ihnen zu kalt sommer
wieder ein bisschen zu machen okay gut
wir sind gutes beispiel mit diesem mit
diesem fall also der hund wird offen
sich getäuscht
die frage ist nur wie sieht das die
täuschung aus hat der hund jetzt einen
falschen gedanken also denkt der hund
jetzt der ball würde geworfen
oder wie ist sie einen schönen das kommt
es zu dieser täuschung deshalb die frage
gut ich glaube er wurde in seiner
erwartungshaltung getäuscht in seiner
annahme annahme ist jetzt aber schon
wieder fast schon wie so eine position
in seinen gedanken also annahme wäre die
form dass der ball jetzt geworfen wird
dass die annahme der ball wird geworfen
ok auf erfahrung
spannende ferien haben wir sehen es gibt
hier zwei möglichkeiten müssen wir jetzt
gar nicht unbedingt entscheiden
natürlich ist so eine unterstellung
eines gedankens aus methodologischen
gründen ist es ja so dass wir gesagt
haben in einer der ersten sitzungen
sollten wir erstmal vorsichtig sein mit
solchen zu sprechen von starken mentalen
phänomen akten wenn wir die ganze sache
auch anders erklären können also es ist
eine methodologische prämisse die sich
dem prinzip der ontologischen
sparsamkeit verdankt wir sollten gewisse
entitäten wie gedanken gedanken sind ja
auch entitäten das sind ja auch dinge
also jetzt nicht objekte im sinne des
greifbaren aber sind objekte das
denkbaren gedanken
wir sollten solche entitäten möglichst
sparsam unterstellen wenn wir die
phänomene so erklären können dass wir
auf solche entitäten verzichten können
und in zelte selbe erklärungs potenzial
daraus ziehen
das ist dieses prinzip der ontologischen
sparsamkeit und descartes es möchte noch
mal betonen weil das immer wieder jetzt
zur sprache kommt die karts sagt ja
nicht tiere haben keine seele tiere sind
maschinen das sagte card nicht er sagt
nur wir sollten sie als dia maschinen
ansehen
er sagt nicht dass maschinen sind sagt
wir sollten sie ansehen als maschinen
weil wir keine guten gründe haben oder
weil wir auch mit einer sparsameren
erklärung wie maschinen dieselben
phänomen erklären können und dann stellt
sich die frage kann eine solche sicht
auf die tiere tatsächlich alle
tierischen phänomene erklären oder
greift sie eben zu kurz und dann kommen
wir als philosophen ins spiel und sagen
es gibt hier aber solche phänomene
tierischen lebens die durch die
maschinen dass maschinen erklärung
setting nicht angemessen beschrieben
werden können also gewisse tierische
verhaltensweisen lassen sich mit diesen
maschinen beschämen nicht fassen
sondern sie verlangen eine zusätzliche
annahmen eine zusätzliche entität und
dann kann man eben wieder gute gründe
anführen so was wie vielleicht gedanken
an das was anzunehmen
darum geht es also immer haben wir
unsere phänomen im griff werden mit dem
phänomen gerecht mit unseren
begrifflichkeit mit unseren vorannahmen
oder brauchen wir müssen wir weitere
entitäten fordern wie gedanken und
verwaltungsreform ist also eine rein
methodologische sache jetzt gar nichts
so seine unter logische sache wie es
wirklich ist dann immer nur wenn wir
diese phänomene haben was wird denen
dann gerecht fassen wir sie alle die
karten eben nicht tiere sind maschine
soll
wir sollten tiere als maschinen ansehen
weil das die einfachste erklärung ist
sparsamste erklärung beachten jedoch
eine unterscheidung wenn wir den
zwischenfall mit dem hund und katze
später kommentieren können wir
bedenkenlos von unserem hund sagen
er dachte die katze sei die eiche
hinaufgeklettert gegensatz dazu würden
wir nur unwillig oder mit einem gefühl
der peinlichkeit sagen er hatte den
gedanken die katze sei die eiche
hinaufgeklettert von einem tier zeigt
man ziemlich selbstverständlich ist
dachte das paar jedoch nicht dass hatte
den gedanken dass p es würden seltsam
klingen wenn wir von einem hund affen
oder den vielen sagten dass der gedanke
dass p i mein' oder aufgefallen oder ihm
durch den kopf gegangen sei
uns allen ist die art von evidenz
vertraut auf grund derer wir von tieren
oder vielmehr von gewissen tieren
behaupten dass sie denken dass dies oder
jenes der fall sein
doch wir sind mit keiner basis vertraut
auf der wir ihnen gedanken zu schreiben
könnten
interessant diese unterscheidung er
dachte die katze soll die
hinaufgeklettert im gegensatz zu den
gedanken die katze seite
hinaufgeklettert
als wir scheinen hier denken auf zwei
verschiedene weisen zu verstehen denken
einmal ihr so einen schwächeren sinne
sind der annahme eines ja eine
orientierung
vielleicht auch eines instinkte neben
dieser schematischen form das p
der gedanke dass p die frage ist die hat
der hund jetzt den gedanken dass
wirklich diese gedanke dass die katze
auf den klinken baum geklettert ist
hat der hund diesen gedanken als jetzt
nicht in dieser sprache bekannt den
gedanken auch in der hundesprache denken
das muss jetzt nicht in deutsch sein
aber diesen gehalt hat der hund diesem
gehalt hat er den als solchen in seinem
kopf sagen hatte den vor augen dass die
frage
das müssen wir jetzt gar nicht definitiv
beantworten da können sie gerne dann
auch ein essay drüber schreiben aber das
ist jedenfalls die frage
personal
die situation
was
ja weil man beim menschen kann man immer
noch die rückfrage stellen warum bist du
denn jetzt hier lang gegangen
beim menschen kann man ja fragen warum
bist jetzt diesen weg gegangen und dann
wird der mensch sagen weil ich dachte
dass ich bin davon ausgegangen ich hatte
anhaltspunkte dafür dass das die katze
times
ihr könnt es rationalist ihren ja aber
jedenfalls noch unterschieden zwischen
diesen zwei formen denken dass also ich
glaube es gibt so schwache form von
denken
in diesem sinne einfachen orientierung
da ist eine spur die verfolgt wird und
die spur
die jetzt hier verfolgt wird die
gestrichelte die die falsche ist ist für
den hund die kohärente die stimmigste
spur
so könnte man zwar als angesichts dieser
verschiedenen faktoren und die beste
spur
man müsste jetzt beim und nicht sagen er
dachte dass man könnte beim uns sagen es
war aufgrund der äußeren umstände dieser
situation die beste ja soll ich jetzt
sagen entscheidung dass wieder eine
antrag folge hat sich der hund
entschieden aber es war die am main
leuchten das sage ich mal oder am
plausibelsten erscheinende optionen
in dieser situation muss natürlich
bedenken dass hier es sehr schnell geht
da wird nicht viel reflektiert sagt sie
auch da wird sehr schnell gehandelt
aber ich denke so eine rudimentäre form
von entscheidung kann man durchaus zu
grunde legen oder man müsste eben sonst
im kt sischen modell davon ausgehen sie
sagen dieser hunde mechanismus sage
jetzt mal die handelte aufgrund dieser
rahmenbedingungen sodass war die
angesichts dieses mechanismus die
plausibelste option angesichts dieser
ganzen randbedingungen diese ganzen rand
faktoren haben den hund dazu
determiniert diesen weg einzuschlagen
und diese diese handlung oder diese
dieses verhalten tag zu legen weil die
ganzen rahmenbedingung gestimmt haben ja
praktisch mit seinem instinkt
letztendlich so zusammen gestimmt dass
das die einzige mögliche option war auf
so eine situation zu reagieren
so kann man vielleicht auch
interpretieren offenbar ist die card
diese unterscheidung zwischen denken und
gedanken haben entgangen meinem ersten
brief an hayward schreibt er die annahme
das tumbe tiere denken da an die manzako
gitarre sei ein vorurteil und er
begründet den folgen seiner meinung dass
tieren gedanken fehlen des tieres
kombinationen des täters er behandelt
denken und gedanken haben als seien sie
gleichbedeutend wir haben jedoch gesehen
dass sie dies nicht sind wir könnten das
interessante an dieser unterscheidung
etwas so darlegen
obwohl wir das wort denken auf tiere
anwenden indem wir es als transit iwes
wert verwenden dass eine position aale
phase zum objekt hat implizieren wir
damit nicht dass das tier diese position
formuliert oder sie sich ausgedacht oder
eine position vor dem geist hatte in dem
wir etwas über das tier sagen verwenden
wären wäre das grammatikalisch gesehen
aber ein proposition ahlen ausdruck zum
objekt hat ohne dass wir damit meinen
dass das tier psychologisch tatsächlich
an eine proposition gedacht hat hilft
jetzt diese unterscheidung
wir wünschen
ein
tut gut
mit bruder punkt jetzt stellen sie sich
mal vor sie sind einer wahl situation
weil das ist insofern ein gutes beispiel
weil hier
dieser punkt hier das ist eine
entscheidung das ist eine
entscheidungssituation auch denken sie
mal sie wären jetzt in einer situation
nicht vor allem nicht vor zwei bäumen in
hass seien alle ruhe
sie bekommen jetzt ein angebot vorgelegt
denken sie sich mal jetzt kommt eine
person zu ihnen und macht ihn ein
angebot
sie bekommen jetzt zweimal einen job
angeboten einen ganz lukrativen job mit
30 10.000 euro monatsgehalt den nachteil
dieses jobs ist dass sie jeden morgen um
vier uhr schon aufstehen müssen so was
und dass da irgendwie sonstige noch
problematische irgendwelche bedingungen
hat in so eine situation denke ich schon
dass er sich ganz klar position vor
augen legen würden
als dass das ist ein grund dafür dass
position
ich kann nicht mehr ausschlafen ich
werde überwacht vielleicht das könnte
man sagen sie sie kriegen den job 10.000
euro pro monat aber sie werden 24
stunden am tag überwacht hochsicherheits
tätigkeit ist werden sie sicherlich die
meisten von uns würden dann durch die
gründe malz recht liegt oder so wenn
jetzt nicht die abschreckenden punkte so
gravierend wären wenn die so gravierend
werden könnte man würde man vielleicht
gar nicht groß jetzt sich das auf eine
position bringt dann würde
zurückschrecken wenn das irgendwie ein
unmoralisches angebot so passt ja wie
sie müssen die menschen versuchen machen
also und dafür bekommen sie dann
zehntausende euro pro monat da würden
wir vielleicht gar nicht mehr dass in so
eine position reform ja wenn es jetzt
nicht so klar auf der hand liegt ich
glaube schon dass wir ziemlich genau in
diese entscheidungssituation proposition
bilden oder
sagt doch wirklich daran
okay gut das ist wohl diese
unterscheidung die auch hier der autor
sich überlegt hat wenn er sagt er dachte
das ixs oder hatte den gedanken dass ich
sie würden also sagen dieses den
gedanken haben das ist dann eben
überlegen oder reflektieren ja da war
noch in berlin
und den punkten markieren abgeben und
sich einschließen
anbieter sind
dann scheint man sich auf und wollen
macht aber nach regen sind
zu entscheiden
das ist geht in die richtung dieses
lippert experiments dieses liebert
experiment haben sie bestimmt schon mal
gehört wobei das gerade sehr umstrittene
sich schranz immerhin ist man forscher
benannten gezeigt dass tatsächlich
dieses bereitschafts potenzial sich im
gehirn schon aufgebaut hat bevor wir den
knopf gedrückt haben der dann gedrückt
werden soll wenn wir eine bewusste
entscheidung gefällt haben
und dann tritt dieses phänomen auch auf
was die kann die kommilitonen zuvor
gesagt hatte wir rationalisieren im
nachhinein unsere entscheidung so das
ist eine professionelle struktur hat das
wäre natürlich ein argument dafür zu
sagen man kann jetzt unterscheide einen
schwächeren sinne von denken einfach so
eine ganz spontane entscheidung diesmal
direkt bewusst getroffen wird und wenn
sie nicht direkt bewusst getroffen
dann ist sie auch kein richtiger gedanke
dann ist es eben so ein spontanes wegen
was fast schon so automatisch im
hintergrund des bewusstseins vonstatten
geht
so kann man natürlich denken auch
auffassen und wenn das stimmen sollte
ist mehren sich jetzt halt die stimmen
die sagen dieses live experiment beweist
nicht das was es vorgibt zu beweisen ist
dieses experiment möchte nämlich oder
die folgerung wieder ausgezogen worden
waren
dass wir nie bewusste entscheidungen
treffen sondern das alles schon jetzt
endlich im vorhinein in uns unterbewusst
vorbestimmt ist
also es gibt da eine riesen debatte
darüber und wenn das stimmen würde dann
könnte man tatsächlich dieses
bereitschafts potenzial was vor bewusst
schon sich aufbaut im sinne von einem
schwachen begriff von denken bezeichnen
und diese rationalisierung also gründe
zu geben und in einem das form zu
bringen
das könnte man als ein gedanken haben
das ist eine spannende diskussion
also er möchte jetzt unterscheiden
zwischen diesen zwei formen als nächstes
müssen wir festhalten dass wir das wert
denken auf dieselbe weise in bezug auf
menschen verwenden
aufgrund der umstände und des verhaltens
sagen wird dass jemand dachte dass
prionen damit sie sagen dass er an p
dachte oder p formulierte wohl dass ein
fehler in seinen gedanken war nehmen
etwa anderen freundlich sein
in ein angeregtes gespräch vertieft wir
wollen gerade mit einem auto weg seinem
auto wegfahren während er das gespräch
weiterführt kramt er in seiner
hosentasche nach dem autoschlüssel im
wissen dass der schlüssel im
handschuhfach ist sage ich denke der
schlüssel sein seiner hosentasche ich
bin ziehe ich impliziere damit nicht
dass sie sich zu sich sagt oder sich
denkt der schlüssel ist in meiner
hosentasche
die grammatikalische form ist kein
anzeichen der psychologischen realität
also dieses in der hosentasche kramen
das wäre dann letztendlich in diesem
beispiel genau dasselbe wie an dem baum
zu warten und da so zu kratzen am stamm
einem schwachen zu
wie sehen sie das
möchte ihnen das 1
würde
menschen vielleicht zwei
denn
b
und diese eine schwächere form könnte
man den tieren dann zugestehen würden
sie sagen ja also so wie der mann da in
der hosentasche gekramt so denkt das
tier jetzt dass die katze diesen baum
hoch ist würden sie sagen dass die
analogie greift weiter
ich bin mir bewusst dass das beispiel
meines freundes der in seiner
hosentasche gekramt und noch mehr dass
des hundes der am baum kratzt
philosophisches unbehagen hervorruft wie
kann die behauptung mein freund denke
der schlüssel sein seiner hosentasche
korrekt sein wenn er gar keinen gedanken
über den schlüssel hat wie kann die
behauptung der und denke die katze sei
die eiche hinaufgeklettert korrekt sein
angesichts der tatsache dass man von
einem hund nicht mit recht sagen kann er
habe gedanken über irgendetwas ist
halbwegs geneigt zu leugnen dass es
wirklich ist richtig ist diese dinge zu
sagen
ich berufe mich hier einfach auf die
alltagssprache
es ist ganz offensichtlich richtig denkt
den beiden fällen zu verwenden okay aber
jetzt haben wir philosophen problem
jetzt haben wir hier so eine mutation
fast schon des begriffs des denkens
jedes teekesselchen bank und bank
nicht direkt weil es irgendwie sich noch
über schneidet aber jetzt müssen wir
überlegen finden wir jetzt bessere
begriffe für diese zwei form von denken
haben sie vorschlägt die sollten wir
denken 1 nennen das ist den kann 1
dieses szenario mit der hosentasche und
den baum und das denken 2 haben sie da
eine andere technologie als vorschlag
jemand denken ist natürlich auch ein
begriff oder ein wort jetzt mal von der
bedeutend wort denken was sehr alltag
sprachlich verwendet wird war sehr weit
verbindet wird haben sie andere begriffe
dafür
zu denken
nach unten
gut gut man könnte auch noch sagen also
descartes sagt der kapitale die deutsche
übersetzung von ich denke ich bin ist ja
also die lateinische form ist der kosovo
gitarre e gitarre ist im lateinischen
meines wissens schon spezifischer als im
deutschen denken
danke
wie lang nicht mehr getroffen
den gedanken die sich selber auf
verbinden
ich hoffe es
ja aber ist es wirklich so diese
proposition aale struktur das also denkt
jetzt ich habe ich könnte den schlüssel
in meiner hosentasche haben
oder ist es als denkt er wirklich der
schlüssel ist in meiner hosentasche oder
ist nicht so ein bisschen hier so
instinktiv jetzt halt mal so spontan das
ist glaube ich das problem denkt er wird
okay
es könnte in meiner hosentasche sein
also schaue ich jetzt mal nach oder ist
diese hat dieses die hand in die
hosentasche stecken und zu suchen ist es
eben viel spontaner viel weniger mit
bewusstsein begleitet so reflexartig so
ein bisschen aber schon auch intentional
gerichtet in bestimmten kontext sinnvoll
eingeprägt nicht einfach beliebig das
ist der punkt ist es wirklich so ganz
bewusst im kopf des nach dem schlüssel
suchenden vorhanden diese position
nach den schüssen tut das weil ich
normalerweise
gut gut
das würde das auch wieder zum hunde
beispiel mehr bringt der hund hat wohl
auch immer wieder die erfahrung gemacht
dass es dann ebenso ist dass die katze
den baum hoch geht wo sie zuletzt
gesehen
gut also sie haben jetzt einmal
unterschieden zwischen zwei aspekten des
denkens also den akt des denkens und den
gehalt des denkens also das denken und
das gedacht hier mit dieser proposition
die profi soziale struktur bezieht sich
auf das gedacht
ja
nicht auf den denk takt sind auf das
objekt zutrifft im sinne des gehaltes
dachte wir auch
also wiederum der nach dem aus gegen die
caps und aktiven worden und der der acht
des sables also das volk über das
ergebnis des wörther also wer jetzt mein
gedanke mit dem immer weiter lernen und
verinnerlichen dass nachdenkens immer
weiter in den hintergrund
setzen
also wir haben offensichtlich hier so
ein fall von sonar gewöhnen wie zu sagen
ich würde es nicht sagen stimmt aber von
einer sehr spontanen handlung basiert
auf häufigen fällen
das wäre so wenn der mann zum beispiel
jetzt oder die frau den schlüssel auf
dem dach des autos suchen führte oder
auf einen baum hoch klettern würde um
den schlüssel zu suchen
baumhof dann wäre der kontext glaube ich
so dass man tatsächlich sagen könnte
hier ist vielleicht wirklich jetzt in
diesem beispiel ein gedanke vorhanden
einfach aufgrund der tatsache wie der
kommilitone sagte das eben in der regel
der schlüssel in die tasche gesteckt
wird
dann wird in der regel nicht aufs dach
gelegt ich meine es gibt solche fälle
auch aber zumindest nicht auf dem baum
gelegt
zb könnte dann eine elster könnte sich
den schlüssel geschnappt haben wenn
jetzt der autofahrer denkt er weist der
schlüssel ist nicht da der finne
entschlüsseln ich erst nicht im
zündschloss ohne reißt die tür auf und
kletterten baum hoch dann müsste könnte
so eine überlegung eben zur kollegen
eine elster hat den schlüssel geschnappt
und ist damit auf den baum geflogen hat
in ihrem nest gelegt
da wäre dann glaube ich aufgrund dieser
mittelbar kite das sind mehrere gedanken
schritte es muss eine elster gekommen
sein
sie mussten sich geschnappt haben und
sie muss damit auch ein baum geflogen
sein dass mehrere stationen das ist
nicht unmittelbar wie in der hosentasche
drin und ich glaube in solchen fällen wo
es um so ein gedankengang gewissen
schlussfolgerung die ems elster kam ist
damit auf einen baum geflogen hatten
abgelegt da ist tatsächlich so ein
gedanke sind dieser proposition zugrunde
gelegt während bei solchen fällen wo das
instinktiv geht wo ein ein gedanke
letztendlich oder nur eine bewegung eine
gedanken bewegung vorhanden ist da dann
vielleicht nicht mit diesem starken
sinne
so eine position angenommen würden muss
ja
weiter
das richtig die frage ist die ob die
jetzt von mir eingeführte unterscheidung
hilfreich ist top mann sagt der akt des
denkens er kann als solcher alleine
bestehen ohne die inhalt des denkens
klar vor augen zu haben
ich bin mir da auch nicht ganz sicher ob
man das
neben steht
er stand
vor dem
liegt hier deswegen bin ich jetzt auch
gerade überlegen wie man es am besten
nennen
vielleicht haben sie ja noch ein
vorschlag
sie sagen
nach den titelkämpfen nach daegu
genau das ist die frage
das ist die frage die frage ist wie wir
das dann nennen wenn wir denken jetzt er
nur für diesen objektiven gehalt
verwenden wollen also den denkt immer an
sohn den kopf binden wollen also eine
position wie nennen wir dann so ein fall
sie haben sich gemeldet
ja ja ok würden sie sagen dass es
intentional aber noch ist
international sind gefordert
ja als ich denke das ist ein guter
hinweis also mir scheint jetzt man muss
es jetzt nicht unbedingt denken im
starken sind aber mir scheint schon dass
seine internationalität im spiel ist da
ist eingerichtet hat
da ist den zweck zweck wird verfolgt die
internationalität ist glaube ich da und
ich glaube dass der grund des der ist
dass wir das ding nennt das die
internationalität hier ist das eine ganz
klar gerichtet ist und der hund der ist
auch ganz klar gerichtet wenn er jetzt
hier hingeht und sein verhalten
fortsetzt als er versetzt praktisch
dieses verhalten der jagd fort ohne dass
das objekt noch in seinem sichtfeld ist
aber die richtung die die hält sich ja
durch er geht diesem impuls oder diesem
trieb nach dieser richtung nach wie sun
so ein endpunkt aber da hört die
richtung nicht auf sondern die richtung
geht weiter die wird gehemmt oder so die
kommt dann so ein endpunkt aber sie hört
nicht auf die gerichte zeit ist da ich
glaube dass das einer der gründe ist
warum man geneigt ist dem hund die
gedanken zu sprechen weil
internationalität sich bemerkbar machen
die frage ist halt immer bedeutet
intensität gedanken zu haben der form
dass sie hatten sie noch gemeint
ja ich habe
denkt
ist ja auch gut
in seiner stadt
gut
ja
ich denke so etwas wie körper wissen
dass wir intuitiv wissen wo unsere linke
hand ist und ich glaube dass diese nach
dem schlüssel suchen auch was von seiner
art körper wissen körper wissen struktur
hat aber was ist wohl allen diesen
fällen skolik ist eine internationalität
schau hin die linke hand hier da selbst
wenn sie nicht mehr da ist ich richte
mich auf etwas und die frage setzt die
muss man sich auf etwas richten was eine
position aale struktur hat das ist die
entscheidende frage muss die
internationalität fundiert sein sagt
jetzt mal in einer proportionalen
struktur die frage weil das scheint
jetzt hier vorausgesetzt zu werden das
als internationalität immer letztendlich
fundiertes oder gerichtet ist deswegen
weil hier ein das vorhaben ist kann es
sich auch intensität geben ohne
proposition ja
ja richtig und ich glaube dass dieser
begriff der internationalität uns hilft
ein mittelweg zu finden zwischen bloßem
instinkt von dem man meint man auch sagt
oder großem reiz reaktions schwimmer und
man sagt das ist ja wie eine maschine
bei decarta sagt ja wenn jetzt hier in
bestimmten umständen eine
richtungsänderung eintritt dann ist die
deswegen so weil das halt so eine
maschine ist die so programmiert ist
input output und die anderen stärken
zeit dass man sagt ja diese richtung und
diese gerichte teilt kommt nur deswegen
zustande weil hier eine professionelle
opposition aller gehalt vorlegt ich
glaube wir können insofern mittelweg
finden als wir sagen es ist weder
vielleicht jetzt in diesem fall dieses
schlüssel finden nur so ein mechanismus
nur sein instinkt oder nur so ein reflex
und es ist auch nicht im starken sind
jetzt ein ganz klarer gedanke sondern es
ist einfach eine internationale bewegung
eine gerichte teilt die aus einem
gewissem interesse erfolgt was jetzt
nicht total bewusst vor augen liegen
muss aber was durchaus in einem
lebewesen fundiert ist und was eben
vielleicht nicht von maschinen vollzogen
werden kann also die frage ist kann es
intentionalen systeme geben die nicht
belebt sind das ist eine ganz spannende
frage können computer intensität
letztendlich entwickeln also viele sagen
dass das eigentliche merkmal des geistes
internationalität ist gerichtet hat
können computer gerichtet sein können
sich computer auf etwas ausrichten
die wird und fordert auch selbst darüber
liegen zu lassen
ich denke hier
die werden
das ist die eigentlich ja das ist gut
aber
von der würde ich sagen
also wäre es anders denken funktioniert
es genauso groß war eigentlich mein
nein
ja aber
nächster halt und
ja aber sie sagen jetzt glauben in der
philosophischen technologie ist eben
glauben ein typisches indizien wort für
eine position er glaubt dass also die
gerade glauben oder meinen oder nicht
nur denken glauben auch selbst als muss
nicht praktisch total piste mich sicher
sein ist auch annehmen dass auch da ist
dann die proposition im spiel
würden sie sagen dass eine bewertung
möglich ist ohne proposition oder kann
ich dann immer kann ich denn überhaupt
erst dann bewerten wenn ich etwas
bewerten muss das was bewertet wird eine
mögliche proposition sein als eine
option könnte man noch seine position
eine option geben in dieser das form vor
augen liegt muss sich nicht um bewerten
zu können die proposition irgendwie vor
augen haben
interessiert ist dass wir auch
normativität eine ganz schwache
das
gut als sie haben sehr zu recht auf
einen weiteren begriff hingewiesen
nämlich normativität ich schreibe jetzt
ja auch noch hin
nicht ganz oben sind ganz unten bei
normativität ich erkläre gleich noch das
ist normativität eben bewertung wertung
ich glaube auch dass ein wichtiges
merkmal des geistes in diesem engeren
sinne normativität es wie sie sagen also
etwas einen vorzug geben etwas etwas
etwas einen wert zu sprechen ein hören
oder nieren mieterin werd ich glaube
auch dass das das merkmal des geistigen
ist ja jetzt könnte man sich fragen ob
in diesem beispiel des hundes hier
einfach normativität der rolle spielt
top bewertung rolle spielt natürlich
muss man sich fragen was wird jetzt
bewertet was wird bewertet das ist die
umstände das ist einfach das setting des
prima fazit setting was irgendwie
gewertet wird aber auch so auf anhand
von welchem kriterium wird hier bewertet
muss der hund dann ein maßstab in sich
haben und wenn er einmal stadt in sich
hat ist der maßstab auch die proposition
habe unabhängig davon ich glaube es ist
sehr wichtig dass sie hier auf diese
normativität abheben weil gerichtet hat
und normativität sehr eng verwandt sind
miteinander sie sie nicht dasselbe
aber sie sind glaube ich etwas was
spezifischen geist ausmacht und was
maschine nicht können
maschinen können mein auge darüber kann
man auch reden keine wirklich bewertung
vornehmen kann kein wertmaßstab
entwickeln und sich daran orientiert der
wertmaßstab muss schon vorgegeben sein
als ein als eine richtlinie an der
verglichen wird aber das ist das nicht
eigentlich wertschätzung sind es ist
einfach nur überprüfen ob es ein fall
von dem ist oder nicht das habe was
anderes als etwas normativ zu beurteilen
sie hatten sich noch gemeldet
naja stimmt uns aber mit dem problem
ein
daher sei
[Musik]
ein anderer hinzu
über 100
die märkte
okay die frage wer jetzt die ob dabei
ein sehr starkes selbstbewusstsein
zugrunde liegen muss diesen zeichen
prozess in dem prozess der bedeutungs
generierung ist die frage also ob bei
tieren eben dann diese starke form von
selbstbewusstsein vorhanden ist ohne
frage würde ich sagen ist es passieren
sodass dass er die wiederholung rolle
spielt die frage ist jetzt die ist dann
bleibt hier nur konditionierungen also
praktisch bekommen zeichen bedeutung
durch auch durch konditionierung also
konditionierung ist auf jeden fall ein
relations' verhältnis wenn adam b immer
wenn ich das mache dann passiert das und
das mache ich nicht nur einmal diese
beobachtung wir hatten bei pierre bel
des beispiel dieses fleisch topfes und
der strafe des herrn des herrchens das
den hund gezüchtigt hat wenn der hund
diesen das fleisch gefressen hat frage
wird dadurch auch bedeutung konstituiert
also was ich hier auch noch hinnehmen
möchte ist noch bedeutung bedeutung ist
auch das passt jetzt zur sprache auch
sprache symantec haben tiere zeichen die
bedeutung haben haben tiere ein
bewusstsein von bedeutung
seine vorschläge
weil
ja und jetzt
aachen
[Musik]
richtig wichtig die sprache ist eben ein
gutes anzeichen und davon ausgehend zu
schließen auf gedanken also wenn sprache
dann gedanken das heißt nicht dass wenn
gedanken dann auch sprache ist richtig
aber wir haben eben ein objektives
kriterium dafür
richtig als ich denke schon dass man
sagen kann wenn sprache vorliegt dann
gedanken aber wenn gedanken vorliegen
dann nicht unbedingt sprache aber
jedenfalls glaube ich bin gedanken
vorliegen dann zeichen dann zeichen mit
bedeutung
also sprach er jetzt ja nicht nur
zeichen kommunikation mit bedeutung
seiner sprache hat eine syntax sprache
gibt vor wie wir die zeichen anordnen
aus der anordnung der zeichen ergeben
sich neue bedeutung ist es ja nicht so
dass ein zeichen staune bedeutung
zugewiesen wird ist je nachdem wie ich
im kontext mit anderen zeichen steht
können ganz andere bedeutung hervorgehen
ich kann jetzt die zeichen beim abc
sie sind dieselben trocken
letztendlich und ich kann aber auch
sagen c b a sind dieselben vorkommnisse
habe in der anton anordnung geben sie
einen ganz neuen sinn
ein
der in
darin
aktionen
in der petition
ich war praktisch aus
klicke hier richtig also man sieht es ja
auch noch bei den buchstaben dass sich
in manchen buchstaben bildhafte gestalt
bewahrt hat im hebräischen alphabet ist
ich glaube ich glaub ich bin ich ganz
sicher also ein zeichen ist zb zum horn
so ein stier horn glaube ich ein anderes
ist ein zelt oder so das sieht man am
ägyptischen noch viel deutlicher
hieroglyphen hieroglyphen sind ja dann
so eine vorform der sprache hieroglyphen
diesen auch semantisch aufgeladen aber
sie haben eben noch diesen bild bezog
sie haben die referenz in sich drinnen
also das worauf sie referieren dass es
im zeichen indem zeichen bewahrt und wir
haben das auch noch bei ono motto
poetischen wörtern wie rabe wo im wort
also in laut bild die die objektes
objekt noch drin ist aber die sprache
zeichnet sich eben dadurch aus dass die
träger ist das eben die materiale ebene
die zeichen ebene letztendlich mit dem
bezeichneten in gar keinem direkten
bezug mehr ist bildhaften bezug sondern
also völlig willkürlich natürlich
definitiv festgelegt aber es muss nicht
mehr wohnort poetisch oder bildlich sein
und ich denke auch dass man das als
einen prozess sehen kann also das denken
hat sich so langsam im laufe der
evolution
er ist durch bildliche symbolik dann
durch ihre prüfen und so weiter immer
mehr abstrahiert vom konkreten dieses
eben ein ganz bitteres zeichensystem
wurde das hat man lange prozess aber
ich glaube wir können aus dem vorliegen
von sprache ganz klar schließen auf das
vorhandensein von gedanken natürlich
heißt das nicht dass wir jetzt keine
sprache da legt auf den ersten blick
dass dann keine gedanken da sein müssen
aber wir müssten zumindest irgendwelche
rudimentären form von bedeutung finden
die zeichen verliehen werden glaube ich
glaube schon
es ist eine spannende frage ob das
vorhandensein von gedanken
notwendigerweise auch bedeutungs
tragende zeichen impliziert die jetzt
sich unterscheiden von bloßen signal
laut
sollte eigentlich davon dass der winter
hat man verständnis
ja ja ich denke das könnte man in diesem
schwachen sinne von denken tun wie es
hier ist so wie wir in die hose passen
als es ist es ebenso eine seine
intension ali-t tauch es ist
unterscheidungsvermögen ganz klar das
hat natürlich häufig auch was für
mustererkennung musste erkennung zu tun
sie sehen das ja schon bei neugeborenen
drücken oder so oder enten dass wenn man
über diesen schatten fliegen lässt von
so einem geier oder so also es gibt so
eine form die man über sie rüber fliegen
lässt wenn man die in zone richtung
fliegen lässt dass es einen flug eines
greifvogels ähnelt dann entwickeln diese
in schutz
in verhalten wenn man diese form aber in
die andere richtung rücken überfliegen
lässt sowie kein geyer fliegen würde
tun sie nicht so wohl dieselbe form ist
und da würde man sicherlich nicht sagen
dass jetzt da in großer tiefe prozess
vorhanden ist und das ist er was
instinktiv etwas eingepflanzt ist man
muss eben immer da unterscheiden aber in
solchen fällen wo eben hier tatsächlich
so ein prozess da ist wo einem tier
gefolgt wird könnte man durchaus im
sinne von der intensität von so einer
schwachen form von gedanke sprechen
in sachen
auch wenn ganz unten
unterschiede
ja ja die frage ist halt
die spannende frage ob eben diese ob es
konzepte sind also überhaupt ob tiere
über begriffe verfügen das ist völlig
ist die frage
das ist nicht geklärt und dann ist noch
eine frage ob diese begriffe wenn sie
vorhanden sind ob die bewusst auch
vorliegen
gar nicht
deswegen bitten
die teuren systemen die hingehen
das programm
nicht so
jetzt sicher
so etwas durchgehen
ich denke in solchen fällen sicherlich
nie in solchen rein natürlichen settings
ja
ist die frage wenn wir die plastik
plastikkügelchen hinwerfen
die frage ist halt läuft diese
kategorisierung automatisch ab oder
willentlich bewusst mit mit bewusstsein
oder sogar mit selbstbewusstsein und die
karts stein zu sagen wir haben es nur
damit denken sie es tun wenn wir das
ganze in so eine form bringen könnten
wir müssen es vielleicht nicht bringen
aber bringen könnte sondern dass form
dass das jetzt essen ist und dann
brauche ich dazu auch einen sehr starken
begriff von ich durch den ich mir diese
position im geist bewusst werden kann
und die frage ist halt ob das bei ihnen
der fall ist
das könnten glaubt das nicht einfach so
ein instinkt ist jetzt futter instinkte
komplett was und stütze mich jetzt halt
draußen ob die hühner das sind sonne
oppositionelle zu bringen können oder ob
sie überhaupt müssen ob dieses futter
fressen ob das dieselbe es ist
jedenfalls eine form von intentional i
tät das ist richtig da wird richtet die
hühner richten sich auf etwas das
interesse der hühnerwirt geweckt sie
gehen auf etwas zu also das ist auch das
würde ich auf jeden fall auch bei
hühnern
wie überhaupt bei allen lebewesen in
einer gewissen form annehmen
internationalität gerichtet hat ne
implementieren sind
das muss in der internationalität muss
jetzt nicht so höhere stufe ich
verstanden werden wie sprachliche bezug
nahm aber so kann man glaube ich sehr
sehr schwach schon ansetzen
die frage jetzt eben ob intensität
wirklich eine starke form von
geistigkeit voraussetzt diese gerichtet
ob die bezugs name gut es ist halt immer
die frage wie man das jetzt definiert ob
die bezugnahme begrifflich sein muss
wurde ob sie auch so ein bisschen vor
begrifflich sein kann im sinne eines
interesses eines lebens interesses
hatten sie sich gemeldet und dann hier
ja
auch unsere
die entscheidung fällt
glauben sie an
der
ja
ziemlich zug ein bisschen zu nehmen
sein müssen und überhaupt auch als
beispiel dafür wie leicht man doch
vermeintlich authentische zu schreiten
voran hier international längst zu hause
und wenn man also über die reinen
alexander riedel oder so gut an sagt
alexander
sagen muss ich jetzt denkt sie ihr
sprecher mit
also man ist doch sowieso von herzen
dieses google ding
ja das ist möglich weil diese eigentlich
anscheinend immer auch stan bayern sind
natürlich der kinder steckdose ist und
wenn man sich unterhält und alexa klingt
wie alexander sofort jeder bewusst sein
konzept noch intensiv an sie würden
jetzt pakistan aus meteorologischen
gründen ein tier funktioniert wie alexa
sd card könnte das sagen man könnte
jetzt skeptisch sagen skeptisch sagen
wir brauchen nicht so viele
voraussetzungen machen wir fassen jetzt
einfach das wie alexa auf das system und
sagen alexa hat so ein erkennungssystem
in sich ist schauen auf ähnlichkeiten
ist ein chor prozess wieder stattfinden
hochstufige prozess mustererkennung
könnte das unter diesen begriff fallen
letztendlich und es wird einfach
verglichen bestimmt
also dass man da als mensch eben bereit
ist wieder andere populistisch
vorzugehen und sagt eben denn ein
verhalten vorliegt was unseren
irgendeiner weise ähnelt dann sind wir
bereit solche prädikate wie sprache
gedanken vielleicht sogar
bewusstseinsstrom alexa hat sich damit
etwas gedacht
wer wechselt wieder auf den menschen
erschaffen
gut
gut ja
die wieder auf patienten und hat
im katalog für alle gesagt haben
gepunktet
wer eine schreibt ja ich glaube schon
dass er zb die werke
natürlich ist es also
also ich finde dich
der bescheid
argumente wie schwierig das nicht
also
die kommen
und geist zu schreiben würde das ist
etwa bei diesen seiten
selten
sie ging es nur darum eben weil er erst
lange stärker präsentiert das ja sie
würden sagen dieses denken schwachen
sind von dem ict rede war
es ist eigentlich eher so eine
eigentliche bezeichnung auch wie das in
die hose sind noch lange nach dem
schlüssel suchen wäre
tendenziell so was wie alexa
zuzuschreiben dass da gedacht wird
progressive sie wollten sie würden
einfach betont dass wir sehr schnell
geneigt sind solche dinge zu schreiben
ohne dass wir wirklich der sache auf den
grund gehen letztendlich jahren hatten
noch zwei sprache sagt der sprache bei
der sprache muss flexibel regiert wird
gemalt sagt das über die sprache also
die sprache muss eben sehr sehr flexibel
eingesetzt werden können und nicht nur
bereits reaktionen so in bestimmten
kontexten ganz flexibel anpassbar sein
wir müssen einfach mit den tieren
verschiedene versuche einstellen und die
flexibilität austesten ich glaube dass
wir so eine möglichkeit neben der
sprache mehr auf den grund zu kommen
noch eine meldung dann gehen wir weiter
zum nächsten zitate
richtig richtig
das ist ein spannendes thema wo jetzt
mal auch wieder ein seminar über geben
könnte
man kann jetzt hier das mit blick auf
die tiere machen wurde mit blick auf
computer oder und dasselbe seminar
könnten jetzt auch nur mit diesen fragen
diese ganzen geistige mentalen akte ob
wir die bei maschinen finden
ich glaube es ist wie gesagt nicht aber
es gibt jetzt hat diese entwickelte
neuronalen netzwerke und wenn man sich
das menschliche gehirn anschaut
es ist halt doch ein sehr komplexes
neuronales netzwerk und könnte es nicht
sein dass wenn wir jetzt genug neuronen
kürzlich simulieren und die so dicht
packen wie es nur geht und wann solchen
komplexität zu schalten das dann
irgendwann so eine kritische schwelle
erreicht ist wo dann klar im ergänz also
spontan aufgrund der inhärenten
eigenschaften ein neues phänomen
auftritt bewusst sein könnte das nicht
sein das ist einfach nur eine sache des
grades ist genug dicht gepackten holen
so also dicht oder den verschaltet wie
nur möglich wenn die eine bestimmte
kritisch würde in ihrer masse genommen
haben dann entsteht irgendwie plötzlich
reagiert geistiges kann man sich fragen
ob das eine bearishe sache ist wir
müssen jetzt aber noch weiter lesen ist
nämlich ganz zu ende das zitat dieser
text die nächste schritt zur milderung
des unwohlseins ist interessanter wenn
wir wie in meinem beispiel sagen er
glaubt der schlüssel sein der
hosentasche ist man versucht anzunehmen
gemein behandelt so als ob er den
gedanken hätte der schlüssel ist in
meiner hosentasche genauso handeln der
hund als ob er den gedanken hätte die
verwirrte katze ist diesen baum
geklettert
dies ist ein interessanter schachzug
weil er eine tendenz verrät gedanken zu
haben
als prototyp oder paradigma von dingen
zu betrachten man glaubt andere
verwendung von denkt sein von diesem
prototyp abgeleitet oder verhielten sich
parasitär zu ihm wenn sich diese
verwendungen irgendwie auf den prototyp
beziehen oder sich ihm annähern sind sie
verständlich sonst nicht als ob
le sommer weiter ich glaube dass dies
die falsche idee ist dass diese idee
falsch ist nichts verdient ist für das
paradigma oder den prototypen des
denkens gehalten werden es gibt viele
paradigmen des denkens und keines von
ihnen nimmt eine zentrale stellung in
der verwendung des wortes ein genauso
wenig wie es den prototyp für ein möbel
gibt es gibt verschiedene arten von
möbeln und verschiedene formen des
denkens keine stellt das ding das möbel
oder das denken par excellence dar
es gibt zusammenhänge zwischen den
verschiedenen denkformen das heißt aber
nicht das ist eine wesentliche natur des
dinkels gibt oder dass die ding form auf
ein zentrum hin konvergieren es gibt
keinen grund für die überzeugung dass
der begriff des denkens eine derartige
einheit hat es ist eine faszinierende
frage warum es ein so starkes bedürfnis
gibt das phänomen gedanken zu haben als
etwas zu verstehen dass ein zentrum hat
habe ich wage es nicht nicht bei dieser
gelegenheit dazu zu äußern ich
beschränke mich auf die bemerkung dass
der glaube es gäbe ein zentrum in dem
etwas ist jeglicher berechtigung in bern
das ist jetzt ganz interessant auf die
card zu beziehen weil die karts eben
dieses zentrum in dem etwas geschieht
das ich ist das ist bei de cati
voraussetzung das ist ein einheits punkt
gibt es argumentiert der dass das ist
gar kein zentrum braucht gar kein
zentrum und dann könnten wir tatsächlich
in so einem schwachen sinne von denken
sprechen wenn es nicht dieses einheits
zentrum haben muss dieses nicht
sich jetzt ein bisschen verkehr gezogen
gedanken und irgendwie auf den marinas
den vierten rang
diesen experimenten und den mut die
immer in die situation bringen ihn
völlig neu ist und die andere frage
und niemand macht und einen möglichen
schlüssel aus irgendwann steigt morgens
in den kiezen
dann hätten
der text
die wissens bestand eben noch
zugegriffen wird wieder zurück ins
nachdenken
ich darf das ich mal
ja
richtig genau kann sagt also dass ich
denke muss alle meine vorstellung und
auch gedanken begleiten können das heißt
nicht dass es das ich gibt das heißt
auch nicht dass das ich jetzt ein
gegenstand ist aber es ist die bedingung
der möglichkeit von gedanken erkannt hat
auch so einen starken einheits begriff
kant würde wohl auch von tieren sagen
sie denken eigentlich nicht weil sie
kein transzendentale ssig haben die
karts denkt dass ich sehr dringlich sehr
objektiv kann denkt es sehr formal ist
einfach die form die unser denken
bestimmt wo nicht diese form des ichs
vorhanden ist da liegt auch nicht das
denken vor und da wird jetzt dagegen
argumentiert mit diesem text
ich möchte jetzt am ende noch mal kurz
was sagt ihr hier genau also jetzt
wieder hier eben noch mal ein fazit
bringen also kehren wir zu den
beobachtungen zurück dass die form er
dachte dass nicht die ganze nicht die
formel der gedanke dass p fiel im 1 nach
sich zieht dasselbe gilt für eine ganze
menge proposition erwerben sie und ich
bin merke etwa dass robinson vorsichtig
geht und sie fragen warum mich antwortet
weil er bemerkt dass der weg glatt ist
ich bin pink implizieren nicht dass ihm
die proposition dieser werke ist glatt
in den sinn gekommen sei ein weiteres
beispiel ich winke eine man zu da
gegenüber wohnt später werde ich
vielleicht zu jemandem sagen ich habe
heute kasper gesehen
es mag war es sein dass ich kasper
erkannt habe erkannt habe dass der mann
auf der anderen seite des hofes kasper
ist aber nicht dass ich im stillen
dachte das ist kaspar wenn wir die
proportionalen werden beiseite lassen
uns emotionen empfindungen zu wenden so
ist es eindeutig falsch dass jemand
immer wenn er wütend ist an die
proposition denkt nicht bedeutend wurde
dass jemand immer wenn er einen schmerz
in bayern findet den gedanken in den
sinn kommt ich habe schmerzen in meinem
bein
die karts lag mit seiner meinung falsch
dass unsere findungsphase gedanken
einschließt menschliche empfindungen
schließen nicht immer gedanken mit allen
dies gehört noch nicht einmal zu ihren
charakteristika
also das ist jetzt gegen die kt sich
auffassung das sind tiere das ist
lateinisch und ihre empfindung dass das
auf das ich bezogen ist und auch ein
gedanke ist an position geholt hat
er bringt es mit dem beispiel die wir
auch diskutiert hatten
wenn wir diese tatsache zur kenntnis
nehmen sollte uns dies bei der einsicht
unterstützen dass die kluft zwischen uns
und zumindest in höheren der niederen
tieren nicht so groß ist wie descartes
angenommen hat seine verzerrte sicht war
teilweise durch seine doktrin bedingt
das mentale phänomen dass menschen immer
proportional sind die karts behauptung
dass eine wesentliche natur das denken
sei bedeutet eigentlich seine
wesentliche natur besteht im denken von
positionen
wenn wir dies die ungeheuerlichkeit
dieser übertreibung des proposition
ahlen im menschlichen leben betrachten
darf unser wiederwählen tieren
proposition ahles dinge zu schreiben und
nicht mehr dazu veranlassen ihnen eine
ganze palette von formen des fühlens der
wahrnehmung des merkens und erkennens
abzusprechen die beim menschen meist
nicht proposition aller art sind hier
nicht professioneller charakter
kennzeichnet sie nicht als weniger
wirkliche formen des bewusstseins ok
also sagt diese sachen hier wurden und
so weiter nicht von empfinden die
gehören sind bewusstsein sache aber sie
sind nicht selbstbewusstsein
es ist es glaube ich sie können jetzt
nicht sprechen ich glaube um eine
position zu haben davon
empfinden das brauchen wir
selbstbewusstsein was dazu tritt als
empfinden plus selbstbewusstsein ergibt
die proportionale struktur empfinden
bloß bewusstsein ist eben gerade dieser
fall von denken wie wenn wir jetzt in
die hosentasche fassen und nach dem
schlüssel suchen
das ist der unterschied die karte hatte
wohl soll jetzt jedenfalls der text
gemeint diese ganzen akte hier
es sind nur möglich wenn sie auf fand
ich auch weil ich denke auf ein
selbstbewusstsein bezogen sind und dann
haben sie sicherlich wenn sie auch wenn
ich denke gezogen sind haben wir
sicherlich die reflexion dieses aktes so
deutlich vor augen dass wir es ihnen auf
eine proportionale form bringen können
wenn diese akte mit ich denke verbunden
sind dann ist liegt darauf liegt auf der
hand dass ich denke ich empfinde ich
empfinde dass das der fall ist wenn ich
das selbstbewusst werden lassen
letztendlich nicht also wenn wir jetzt
endlich hierüber alsonso einkreist
rummachen selbst bezüglichen kreis
daraus folgt in meinen augen dass mir
das oppositionelle vor augen haben
können weil wir dadurch in eine
reflexive haltung zu diesen akten gehen
wenn wir die reflektieren zu
objektivieren dank selbstbewusst sind
dann können sie vorliegenden form einer
proportionalen struktur wenn sie
hingegen nur mit bewusstsein verbunden
sind
wenn wir es phänomenal bewusst haben
dann scheint damit nicht einher zu gehen
dass wir sie als proposition ahlen akt
vor augen liegen haben
und das sagt jetzt der auto könnte bei
tieren der fall sein ebenso wie es bei
menschen der fall ist sie brauchen nicht
selbstbewusst sein sollen braucht nur
bewusst sein
spannende these
dennoch gibt es eine kluft wie unser
widerwille tieren gedanken zuzuschreiben
zeit ich hatte einmal ein airedale
terrier der es nicht leiden konnte
gebadet zu werden im laufe der zeit
versteckt er sich jedes mal wenn er die
bade vorbereitung bemerkte ich sage ohne
zu zögern er merkte dass ihm ein bart
bevorstand oder dass er aus erfahrung
lernt das auf bestimmte vorbereitung ein
bad folgte
ich werde nicht versuchen eine aussage
darüber zu machen ob diesen und darauf
hinausläuft der sei rational gewiss
würde ich ihm jedoch nicht den gedanken
zu schreiben nicht schon wieder ein
christliches bad in dieser beziehung
würde ich eine stärkere position als
descartes einem er sagte 'mann können
nicht beweisen dass tiere in ihrem
körper verborgene gedanken hätten oder
nicht und räumte damit die möglichkeit
ein dass es schließlich doch gedanken
haben aber die idee dass wir nicht
bestimmen können ob hunde gedanken haben
in sich haben stiftet furchtbare
verwirrung
nehmen wir an wir wüssten alles was ich
in ihren körpern verbirgt wie könnten
wir sagen welche von diesen dingen
gedanken sind
diesmal das noch kurzen dann sind aber
auch fertig die vorstellung dass hunde
verborgene gedanke haben könnten ist
eine falsche fährte
die relevante frage ist ob sie gedanken
ausdrücken ich denke die antwort ist
ganz klar negativ kehren wir zu robinson
zurück der auf einem glatten weg geht
allein schon an der seinen vorsichtigen
bewegung sehen wir dass er dessen gewahr
ist die unsicherheit füßen ist aber wir
können anhand dieser eigenheit seine
bewegung nicht bestimmen ob ihm der
gedanke der weg ist glatt in den sinn
gekommen ist bei den menschen können wir
oft herausfinden ob ihm der gedanke dass
pina sinn gekommen ist entweder weil wir
mitbekommt wie er sagt dass p
oder weil er nachträglich bezeugt dass
ihm der gedanke dass er gekommen ist bei
tieren können wir zu keiner dieser
beiden möglichkeiten sofort zuflucht
nehmen
der entscheidende unterschied liegt im
besitz von sprache wenn sich ein hund
auf dem glatten wie ebenso vorsichtig
bewegen würde können wir zu recht sagen
der hund sei dessen gewahr dass der
gedanke dass der weg klappt ist das
könnten wir sonst noch tun um
herauszufinden ob ihm der gedanke dieser
weg ist glatt eingefallen oder den sinn
gekommen ist dem unterfangen
herauszufinden ob der hund diesen
gedanken hat oder nicht können wir
keinen sinn abgewinnen das ist noch eine
spannende frage die wir noch in die
nächste sitzung übernehmen wollen
in der wir dann aber auch endlich dann
auf unseren nächsten text zu sprechen
können kommen nämlich von donnell
davidson zum thema rationale lebewesen
gehen wollen wir unbedingt der nächsten
sitzung der weiter besprechen
dann bis nächste woche